- When you take on an
engagement as a lawyer,
the worst thing that you
think that can happen
is you'll lose the case.
You don't think you're gonna
get disbarred as a result
and you certainly don't think
that you're going to jail,
especially when you're
suing a private company.
But some people have accused Chevron,
the oil company, of doing just that,
putting lawyer Steven Donziger in jail
for his lawsuit against them.
But is that what really happened
and is that what happened
in this particular case?
Well, once upon a time,
lawyer Steven Donziger famously
won a case against Chevron
for polluting the Amazonian
rainforest in the Ecuador.
He won billions of dollars,
but Donziger has been
disbarred as under house arrest
and the plaintiffs in that
case have never been paid.
And now the eyes of the legal
world are on New York City
where Donziger's contempt of court trial
has captured the attention of celebrities,
legal commentators and social media.
So what is the Steven
Donziger case all about?
Hey, Legal Eagles,
it's time to think like a
lawyer under house arrest
because that's where
Steven Donziger has been
while he awaits the outcome
of a contempt of court trial
that stems from a case he
started way back in 1993.
So today we're going to analyze
the Chevron vs Steve Donziger ordeal.
How do we get here?
Who bribed whom and who is the real threat
to the rule of law,
former attorney Steve
Donziger or Chevron Oil?
But to understand what's
happening right now in New York,
we have to understand
what some people call
the Amazon Chernobyl.
The Donziger saga involves
two different legal disputes.
First, there was the case
where indigenous people
from Ecuador sued Chevron
for destroying parts
of the Amazon rainforest.
Steve Donziger was their lawyer.
And although the plaintiff's won,
they have been unable to
collect the $9.5 billion
for legal issues that we'll
talk about in a second.
The second dispute is Chevron civil case
against Donziger himself,
where the company has accused him of fraud
and bribery in violation of
American racketeering laws.
Donziger lost this lawsuit
and then failed to comply
with multiple court orders
that led to contempt of court charges
and this is why Donziger
is currently on trial.
But the story of this
goes way back to the 1960s
when Texaco teamed up
with a military junta
that it seized power in
Ecuador to drill for oil
in the Amazon.
These tribes were hunter gatherers
who didn't even have a word for oil,
but it's alleged that
Texaco's activities produced
16 billion gallons of toxic runoff,
a lot of which wound up in
unregulated shallow pits,
but most of the toxic sludge
was simply dumped into rivers.
To facilitate the drilling,
Texaco created a company
town called Lago Agrio,
which became a typical oil boom town
with all the components needed
for drilling infrastructure,
concrete walls, holding
tanks, massive drills
and miles of pipelines.
But in 1992,
Texaco ended its Ecuador operation
leaving behind this infrastructure
plus hundreds of open oil pits,
thousands of waste pits near
drinking and fishing water
and untold amounts of
contaminated wastewater.
How bad was the situation in Ecuador?
Well, even now more than 50 years
after Texaco started drilling,
the people who live there
can't get clean water
from the river so they collect rainwater
or walk six miles to
fill plastic water jugs
from a water truck provided
by a Spanish oil company.
This is why the situation for local people
has been called the Amazon Chernobyl
and it's also why in 1993,
Donziger and a small team of lawyers
filed a lawsuit on behalf
of the people of Lago Agrio.
They filed the case in New York
where Texaco was headquartered.
The company whose assets were
eventually acquired by Chevron
sought to remove the
litigation to Ecuador,
meaning take the litigation
from the United States
and put it in Ecuador.
Strategically, the company assumed
that they would have a better shot
at winning the case in Ecuador,
where they still had political clout.
This complicated jurisdictional battle
took 10 years to resolve.
Chevron won and the case
was removed to Ecuador
and Chevron has always maintained
that Ecuadorian contamination
is the responsibility of Texaco,
even though Chevron inherited
the company's assets
around the world and runs
Texaco as a subsidiary.
And it also puts a fair amount
of blame on Petroecuador,
the state run petrochemical company.
Not surprisingly though,
even after the case
was removed to Ecuador,
the case still took years to complete
as the parties to the suit
and independent groups
completed over 60,000 lab
tests on soil and water.
The results quote overwhelmingly
showed contamination
traceable to Texaco,
but the testing process was contentious
and both sides crossed ethical lines.
So we'll start with
Chevron's dirty dealing.
It's alleged that Chevron
concocted a scheme
where it sent soil and water samples
to a friendly lab for favorable results.
We know about this because Diego Borja,
a Chevron contractor
who had been the Chevron
worked with his uncle and wife
to create four front companies,
which posed as independent labs.
There are recordings of
Borja discussing his ability
to ruse enough evidence
to swing the case to the
plaintiffs if need be.
He said that Chevron understood
exactly what he was implying
and that the company promised
that he would be taken care of.
Crime does pay, Borja had
laughed in one of these calls.
Chevron eventually helped
Borja and his family
move to the U.S.
Chevron paid Borja's legal fees,
helping him to become a
naturalized American citizen.
The company also paid his
rent and gave his family
a monthly stipend.
Chevron paid Borja over $2 million
and those are just the payments
the plaintiffs were able to trace.
This raises a question,
is it legal to pay a non-expert
witness for testimony?
And the answer to that is actually no.
Fact witnesses generally may be reimbursed
for expenses incurred in time
lost in connection with litigation,
but they can't be paid
to testify or not testify
for the substance of their testimony.
Chevron has declined to
comment on Borja's allegations
beyond stating that they are
protecting him from retaliation.
An American judge denied further discovery
into the nature of the
Borja Chevron arrangement.
But let's talk about the allegations
against Donziger himself.
Chevron has accused
Donziger of dirty dealing
and in a diary entry later
obtained by a U.S. court,
Donziger admits that
he had a secret contact
with the court appointed expert
who was supposed to be independent.
Donziger described the situation
as a quote bargain with the devil.
Quote we can't win with the
devil because they, Chevron,
can always pay more.
There's also evidence that Donziger paid
for the expert report and
may have written parts of it
although American lawyers
don't write expert reports.
In our legal system,
lawyers do pay experts
and exert some influence
how the reports are written.
In the Ecuadorian case, the expert report
was written by a Colorado
company called Stratus.
Many experts say that the expert report
scientific analysis was sound.
However, according to a
report in Rolling Stone,
Chevron played hardball
with Stratus, pressuring
insurance companies
to cancel its coverage with Stratus
and leaning on its clients
to cancel contracts with the company.
Eventually Stratus faced
bankruptcy in a move
that may or may not be related
its executive signed an
agreement with Chevron
explicitly disavowing its
work in Ecuador as fraudulent.
But to get back to the verdict
in the Ecuadorian case,
this issue with the Stratus
report may be nothing more
than a distraction from
the bigger picture.
The Ecuadorian court
granted Chevron's motion
to exclude the expert
report from consideration.
In the end,
the Ecuadorian court
found for the plaintiffs
without relying on the
controversial report.
And this nine year legal saga generated
a 220,000 page record with
over 100 expert reports,
testimony from dozens of witnesses,
scientific data from 54
court supervised inspections
and independent health evaluations.
And in the end,
the court found the Texaco Chevron
had dumped billions of gallons of water
containing toxic chemicals in waterways
and on the jungle floor,
used waste pits that contaminated the soil
and groundwater, never cleaned
up the frequent oil spills,
maintain a policy of destroying documents
related to oil spills
and burning natural gas
that contaminated the air.
On February 14th, 2011,
a judge entered a judgment against Chevron
for over $19 billion,
which was later reduced to $9.5 billion.
It was upheld by Ecuadorian
appeals courts in 2012 and 2013.
And this was pretty
much the last good thing
that happened for the
Lago Agrio plaintiffs.
So that takes us to the American case
of Chevron versus Donziger.
After Chevron lost the Ecuadorian case,
it dropped a bombshell that would change
the trajectory of this whole entire saga.
They alleged the Donziger
bribed an Ecuadorian judge.
After the trial,
former Ecuadorean judge Alberto Guerra
came forward with a
story that the legal team
for the Ecuadorians offered him a bribe
to ghost write the
judgment against Chevron.
Guerra said that he asked
Chevron for a bribe first
and they turned him down so
he then went to Donziger.
He says he saw bribes on behalf
of judge Nicholas Zambrano,
the judge who actually
issued the final judgment
in the case.
And according to Guerra,
he and Zambrano shared
$500,000 in kickbacks
paid by Donziger.
This is the testimony that Chevron used
to sue Donziger under U.S.
anti-racketeering laws,
which takes us to a rare case of RICO.
The organized crime control act of 1970,
also known as the Racketeer Influenced
and Corrupt Organizations act or RICO
was originally enacted
to help the government
stop organized crime.
RICO generally has two different flavors,
civil and criminal.
The government can prosecute
a person who operates
or requires an enterprise
through a pattern
of racketeering activity.
RICO's criminal penalties
include imprisonment
up to 20 years and even life
depending on the activity.
And when Congress passed RICO,
their expectation was that the
vast majority of RICO claims
would be brought by federal prosecutors.
However, the law also
had a civil component
that allows private persons and entities
to file RICO lawsuits.
RICO civil remedies
provision section 1964C
states quote any person
injured in his business
or property by reason of a
violation of section 1962
of his chapter may sue therefore
in any appropriate U.S. district court
and shall recover threefold
the damages he sustains
and the cost of the suit,
including reasonable attorney's fees.
Chevron as a private party
and person uses section
to argue that the Ecuadorian verdict
was obtained fraudulently.
And while the Ecuadorian
verdict was upheld on appeal
in Ecuador, Chevron doesn't
need an Ecuadorian court.
All it needed to do was cast out
on the original legal proceedings,
which would of course help
them to avoid paying a judgment
in the United States.
So let's talk about
Guerra's testimony here.
In 2011, Chevron sued Donziger
and the plaintiffs alleging fraud
and using Guerra's
testimony to prove its case.
During the litigation,
Guerra admitted that when he was a judge,
he accepted bribes and fixed cases.
He also admitted that Chevron
relocated him and his family
to the U.S. and compensated
him in much the same way
that it paid Borja.
However, Chevron says
Guerra legitimately feared
for his life and facilitated
a move to the United States
to protect him.
Erwin Chemerinsky, basically the guy
that everyone learns constitutional
law from in law school
and also the Dean
of the University of California
Irvine School of Law,
signed a declaration
criticizing the Guerra evidence
quote if a party or its
counsel were permitted
to pay a testifying witness
for physical evidence
beyond the reasonable
value of that evidence
and to pay the witness
a salary in exchange
for an agreement to testify,
there'll be little left to the rule
against compensating fact witnesses.
That is precisely what has occurred here.
Not withstanding, U.S.
district judge Lewin Kaplan
found clear and convincing
evidence that Donziger
and the plaintiffs committed fraud,
bribery and extortion to
obtain judgment over Chevron,
quote Guerra on many occasions
has acted deceitfully and broken the law,
but that does not necessarily mean
that it should be disregarded wholesale.
Judge Kaplan also issued a new junction
barring the Ecuadorian plaintiffs
from enforcing the judgment
in American courts.
Now Chevron leveraged the Kaplan decision
in the Guerra evidence internationally,
convincing an arbitration
tribunal in the Hague
that the Ecuadorian judgment
violin Chevron's rights.
Interestingly, at the arbitration
in front of the Hague,
Guerra recanted his testimony again
and claimed that he lied about
the whole kickback scheme.
He claims he approached Chevron
with an offer to manufacture testimony
and to increase his bargaining position.
He told Chevron plaintiffs
offered him a bribe
and Guerra testified that
Chevron promised to pay him
for making up a story.
During his testimony,
Guerra admitted that he has no evidence
of the alleged bribes and forensic experts
from both parties agree
that the draft judgment
was never found on either Steve Donziger's
or Guerra's computer, but
similar to the American courts,
the Hague tribunal rule
that no court should enforce
the judgment because parts of it
were corruptly ghost written
in return for the promise of a bribe.
Now, after judge Kaplan's ruling,
Donziger appealed to the
U.S. Court of Appeals
for the second circuit,
which is the Court of Appeals
is one step below the Supreme Court.
Donziger argued that Judge
Kaplan's expansive reading
of the RICO statute was
not supported by case law.
The second circuit disagreed
finding that section 1964
was meant to allow private
citizens to be prosecutors
or attorneys general in
this private right of action
quote section 1964 subsection A
gives federal courts
jurisdiction to hear RICO claims
and sets out general remedies
including injunctive relief.
Subsection B makes it clear
that the court on the application
of the attorney general
has authority to grant
temporary injunctive relief
even before its final
adjudication and subsection C
provides a private right
of action for any person
injured in his business or property
by reasons in violation of section 1962.
The second circuit held that
there is no legal principle
that stops the U.S. court
from granting a company relief
from a foreign verdict.
And Judge Kaplan's orders
certainly aided Chevron's attempts
to avoid judgment.
And not only did this injunction bar
in a U.S. court from
enforcing the judgment,
it also set up a constructive trust
that would hold any proceeds
that plaintiffs obtained
anywhere else in the world.
Now, some have criticized the strategy
and the second circuit's decision
as giving private actors like corporations
and other way to go after people
who criticize their actions
in the context of free speech.
This is known as generally a SLAPP suit.
A SLAPP is an acronym
for a strategic lawsuit
against public participation.
And it's interesting because
in this particular case,
what Chevron argued successfully
was that getting a lawsuit
or at least extorting,
allegedly extorting a lawsuit
in a foreign jurisdiction was
a violation of RICO statute.
Even if a verdict is
obtained in bad faith,
it's extremely unusual
to claim that a lawsuit
or the legal system in general
is an arm of a RICO enterprise,
but that more or less takes
us to the contempt trial,
which is why Steven Donziger
is under house arrest to this day.
Based on the allegations of
impropriety against Donziger
or I guess at this point
the findings of impropriety
against Donziger,
Chevron sued Donziger personally,
and the court ordered
Donziger to pay Chevron money
that he had earned by selling shares
in the Ecuadorian judgment.
Eventually Kaplan ordered
Donziger to pay Chevron $813,000.
This is the order that has led
to Donziger's current trial.
Chevron filed motions with the court,
alleging that Donziger was hiding assets
in order to avoid paying up.
And the court ordered Donziger
to produce his cell phone,
computer and other documents
so that the court could review
evidence about his assets.
Donziger refused to comply
with the court's discovery orders.
He argued that the materials
would reveal decades
of communications he had with his clients,
which arguably would be protected
by attorney client privilege.
And while that might be true,
even if this information would reveal
some protected communications,
courts deal with this kind
of sensitive information
all the time.
Judges often review
the material in camera,
which means only the court
is looking at these documents
and they often allow redactions
and they can issue orders
preventing the other side
from seeing protected information,
but by refusing to comply
with the court's orders,
Donziger found himself
in contempt of court.
And here's where things
went sideways again.
The judge, Judge Kaplan
appointed a special prosecutor,
Rita Glavin, a former DOJ attorney now
in private practice to
handle the contempt case.
Glavin's role was to prosecute
on behalf of the court.
The Manhattan AUSA twice told the judge
that it was overtaxed and
didn't have any lawyers to spare
in this contempt trial.
Kaplan went ahead with the
prosecution using Glavin
and something else that's unusual,
the maximum penalty for
misdemeanor contempt
to federal court
in this situation is about
six months in prison.
However, the judge ordered Donziger
to be held under home confinement
because he's allegedly a flight risk
due to his interest in Ecuador.
Donziger has been under house
arrest for more than 600 days,
more than four times
the length of time that he
could be confined in prison
if he was convicted of the offense.
Donziger supporters, which
include Nobel laureates
and international law organizations
said that this is unprecedented
for a federal misdemeanor case.
They and Donziger also argued
that given the punitive
nature of this prosecution,
he's entitled to a trial by jury.
The court has disagreed so Donziger's fate
will be decided by a judge.
Thus Donziger appears to
be in a Catch 22 situation.
He's been confined for more than the time
that he could be sent to jail
and is on the hook for $800,000.
Meanwhile, the facts that
have been established
in the American federal courts
say that he bribed a judge
and the Supreme Court
has denied Donziger's
petition for certiorari.
So this means that the RICO case is over.
So the criminal contempt case
is an offshoot of Chevron
civil action against Donziger.
In that case,
judge Kaplan ruled that Donziger obtained
the $8.6 billion judgment
in Ecuador against Chevron
through fraudulent and corrupt means.
Judge Kaplan's judgment enjoying Donziger
from enforcing the Ecuadorian judgment
in the United States were
attempting to profit from it.
Donziger appealed his
case to the Supreme Court,
which did not grant certiorari,
which means the Supreme Court
did not take up the case.
And that meant that Chevron won the case
and could move on to enforce
the judgment of the court.
And when a plaintiff wins a judgment,
the next step usually includes
determining what assets
the defendant has to satisfy
the monetary judgment.
Against that backdrop,
Judge Kaplan ordered Donziger
to transfer to Chevron
all property that he had,
or might later obtain
that could be traced to
the Ecuadorian judgment.
And in 2018, Chevron initiated
post-judgment discovery
to identify assets available
to enforce a judgment against Donziger.
So discovery can come at
the beginning of a case
before the case is over
and it can also come
after for the case when
you have to figure out
how you're going to get the money
from the person that you
just won the money against.
And the court also ordered discovery
to assess Donziger's compliance
with the judgment's injunctive provisions.
Donziger resisted this discovery
refusing to provide the
requested information
and refusing to transfer property.
He sent a letter to judge Kaplan stating
that he would prefer to be
found in contempt of court
and then challenged the contempt findings
in court proceedings.
The judge said Donziger should turn over
his electronic devices
to a forensic expert,
so they could be imaged and examined
for responsive documents.
Donziger refused to do this
and so he was found in contempt of court
and in the latest proceedings,
Judge Preska clearly expects Donziger
to attack her impartiality
as he's done in the past
and as he's done with Judge
Kaplan and in late July,
Judge Preska finally issued her rule
and she found Donziger
guilty of six counts
of contempt of court.
The 245 page ruling is
bound to be controversial.
Judge Preska agreed with Donziger
that he may be the only
lawyer ever prosecuted
by a private special counsel
in the Southern district of New York.
The judge said that the
uniqueness of the circumstances
didn't render the prosecution
inappropriate or untoward.
Judge Preska's ruling
said that Donziger refused
to comply with the court orders
and that was an attack
on the rule of law quote
at stake here is the fundamental principle
that a party to illegal action
must abide by court orders
or risk criminal sanctions,
no matter how fervently he believes
in the righteousness of his cause,
or how much he detests his adversary.
The judge did not
consider the wider context
of the Chevron saga except to point out
that she believed Donziger
was sincere in his beliefs
that he's being persecuted
and so are his clients.
As the judge pointed out, quote,
this case, however, is wholly unconcerned
with the debate regarding
any responsibility
Chevron might bear for that pollution.
The only question before this court
was the very specific
question of whether Donziger
had committed criminal contempt
in violation of 18 USC 401.
To secure a criminal
conviction for contempt
of a court order,
prosecutors have to prove three elements.
One that the order was issued.
Two, that the defendant's disobedience
were disregard of that order and three,
the defendant's knowledge or willfulness
in disobeying that order.
The judge ruled that the
prosecutor had proved
beyond a reasonable doubt
that Donziger received notice
of the court orders that
he ignored the court orders
and that he did so willfully.
Donziger on the other hand argued
that his acts were ethically grounded
in principled objections that
lawyers are permitted to make
when they object to an abuse of power.
He cited the case of In re McConnell,
which reversed a contempt
conviction of a lawyer
who insisted on pursuing a forbidden line
of questioning at trial.
However, Judge Preska said that
McConnell didn't apply here
since the contempt charges in that case
were under a different section of 401,
which prohibits in court acts
that quote obstruct the
administration of justice.
Rather than the third
section of section 401,
which is the statute that
Donziger was charged under.
Section 4013 prohibits disobedience
of lawful court orders.
The judge also took issue
with Donziger's assumption
that the McConnell case allows
lawyers to defy court orders
so long as their decisions
were quote ethically grounded.
Quote criminal contempt jurisprudence
has no safe harbor for
conscientious objectors.
Indeed, the law is clear that
a party may not challenge a
court's order by violating it.
Instead, he must move to
vacate or modify the order
or seek relief from the Court of Appeals.
Since this was not a trial
about Chevron's
responsibility for pollution,
all Judge Preska could
do was consider the facts
of the contempt charges.
Here, she found the quote,
a lawyer of all people
should know that in the face
of a perceived injustice,
one may not take the
law into his own hands.
By repeatedly and willfully
defying Judge Kaplan's orders,
that is precisely what Mr. Donziger did,
it's time to pay the piper end quote.
The charges here carry a maximum penalty
of six months in prison and
Donziger has already served
over 700 days on house arrest.
So does that mean that he'll
be sentenced to time served?
That's definitely a possibility.
He'll be sentenced shortly,
but we already know that Donziger
will appeal this ruling.
He tweeted a statement
to writing Judge Preska
as a member of the quote Chevron
funded Federalist society
and called his conviction a dark day
for the quote rule of law
for democracy and our planet.
Though of course, Donziger's
chances of winning this appeal
are incredibly slim,
though we probably haven't heard
the last of Steve Donziger.
So if you're like Steve
Donziger and you're locked away
in your home, you'll love
today's sponsor, HelloFresh.
I mean, why would you even
want to leave your home
if you can get HelloFresh delivered?
I'd have to say
I was initially pretty
skeptical about HelloFresh.
I'm a pretty good cook
so I didn't think that I needed the help,
but I actually loved it.
Even for an experienced cook,
HelloFresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes
that I would never try on my own.
Everything I've gotten from HelloFresh
was insanely delicious, easy
to cook and really healthy.
And most recently I made
yogurt marinated chicken
with garlic sauce, pork
tenderloin with cherry sauce
and meatloaf a la mode
and every single one
of those was fantastic
and not something I would
have made on my own.
So if you feel like you've been cooking
the same thing everyday in quarantine,
HelloFresh is a great solution.
And of course, everything was delivered
straight to my door so I
didn't have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets to you
faster than a grocery store
so it arrives at peak
freshness and flavor.
And it's also super easy to save time.
HelloFresh cuts out meal planning and prep
so the recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes to cook,
literally less time to cook
than it would normally
take to do shopping.
And it's also incredibly sustainable.
Since the ingredients are pre-portioned,
there's less prep and less wasted food.
The package aging is almost entirely made
from recyclable or
already recycled content
and HelloFresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25% lower
than that of meals made
from store bought groceries.
So if you would like to try HelloFresh
and I recommend that you at least try it,
you can go to hellofresh.com
and use the code LegalEagle14
to get 14 free meals.
Yes, you can actually get 14
free meals plus free shipping,
or you can just click on the link below.
So again, for 14 free meals,
go to hellofresh.com and
use the code LegalEagle14,
or just click on the link below,
plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews
with explanations of today's legal news
so click on this link or
I'll see you in court.